so the california recall is finally here
it's tomorrow gavin newsom is the
governor of california the problem is
he's a really bad governor and the state
has gotten much worse since he has run
it and this has put democrats across the
country in a tough position obviously
they want to hold power at all costs but
endorsing gavin newsom means they have
to pretend that california is okay which
it demonstrably isn't and you know that
if you live there or have been there
here's just the latest example it kind
of crystallizes it
we were going to play the game what
country is this you would guess brazil
of course when you see this but no it's
not brazil it's melrose avenue in los
angeles watch
look at that store surveillance video
showing two men one with a gun stealing
property from restaurant customers
including a purse a watch and a cell
phone sometime it's been one crime after
another around here a robbery shooting
on july 21st another shooting on august
11th there's been more all along melrose
by the way i'm sorry to our viewers who
are from brazil that was an insult to
brazil brazil is better than that that's
the california dream that's what
democrats are defending larry elder is
trying to change it he is running to
replace gavin newsom as the governor of
california tomorrow we thought we'd
speak to him on the eve of that election
larry eller thanks so much for coming on
um so basically you're running this
recall has forced barack obama kamal
harris and all of them pelosi all of
them to endorse
the inexcusable
well that's right they've all cut
commercials for him they haven't
defended him on crime as you just now
displayed they haven't defended him on
the rise of the cost of living
california just hit an average price of
a home at eight hundred thousand dollars
which is at minimum 150 above the
national average they've not defended
him on the rise of homelessness they're
not defending him on the decline of the
quality of our public schools and the
public school kids were denied a whole
year of in-person education when gavin
newsom's own kids were enjoying
in-person private education they haven't
defended the way he shut down the state
to the point now where a third of all
small businesses are gone forever many
of them owned by black and brown and
asian-american people that the people on
the left like gavin newsom claims they
care about they haven't defended his way
of managing our force that made our
fires more severe they haven't defended
him for failing to add in any real way
to our water infrastructure so now okay
we're running out of water california
has the same water infrastructure that
it had 40 years ago when the state was
half its size we're having rolling brown
outs because we haven't adequately
managed our power grid so these
politicians who've all cut commercials
for them tucker have never uttered the
following magical words gavin newsom has
done a good job for the people of
california
i mean i just don't understand i mean
you know i'm sure there are a ton of
people in california who think well i
don't agree with everything larry elder
says or maybe any of it but they drive
through santa monica and there are
people living it's it you know it's like
calcutta except worse
how can anybody vote for that is a
sincere question
well i don't really understand it either
look 63 of hispanics voted for him just
two years ago now the majority of them
want him out the majority of
independents voted for him two years ago
now the majority want them out you know
crime doesn't have a color doesn't have
a party the rise of homelessness doesn't
have a color it doesn't have a party the
decline in quality of public education
doesn't have a color it doesn't have a a
party i support school choice uh the
number one obstacle to school choice is
the teachers union not teachers teachers
union number one funder of my opponent
gavin newsom is the powerful teachers
union so why black and brown parents
routinely pull that lever for the
democratic party that stops them from
the number one path to escaping poverty
which is to at least finish high school
is beyond me i'm going to break this
jedi mind trick stranglehold that
democrats have over black and brown
voters and that is why i believe obama
and bernie sanders and senator warren
and the others have come to california
and weighed in on this race when they
cannot defend the indefensible record of
my opponent gavin newsom well that's
right and i got to say
you know they've really gone after you
personally gavin newsom has a genuinely
creepy personal life i'm just saying it
i mean it's you can look it up if you
want it's he's weird okay
i don't think you're attacking his sex
life are you or his personal life
aren't you sticking to the issues it
seems like to me
well i'm trying to stick to the issues
but i will tell you i've been attacked
as being a sexist and just day before
yesterday rose mcgowan the actress who
outed harvey weinstein says that six
months before the big expose on harvey
weinstein the sexual predator gavin
newsom's wife called her on behalf of
harvey weinstein's lawyer and said
something to the effect of what can i do
to make you happy what can i do to make
this thing go away now i have no idea
whether or not is true or false all i
know is that had that been alleged
against me that's all i'd be talking
about from now until the day i die but
the washington post new york times
completely oblivious to this story it's
a bombshell story if it were made
against me
well that's exactly right the protector
is a woman we're speaking to rose
mcgowan in just a minute actually funny
you mentioned that larry elder
appreciate your coming on good luck
tomorrow man we're rooting for you well
thank you for having thank you for
having the black face of white supremacy
on your show tucker be sure to vote
tomorrow and vote vote yes on the recall
yes on the recall and then i have a
candidate who i think ought to replace
him his name is larry elder
sorry i shouldn't laugh at that it's so
grotesque but it's just so absurd i
can't i can't help it larry ellen thanks
a million hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else